welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and is the new Republic of Star
Wars overwhelmed corrupt or just stupid
across Star Wars titles like Ahsoka the
Mandalorian in the book above a vet are
wildly creative wolf boy Dave filoni has
taken on the ambitious mission of
connecting the dots between the fall of
the Empire and Return of the Jedi and
the rise of the first order and the
force awakens but what is the cost of
connecting these dots do we need them to
be disconnected because at the end of
the day it's gonna be someone's fault
and whose fault is it gonna be ever
since on the Mandalorian we heard the
term strandcast and saw snoke clones
floating in a tank followed by moth
Gideon clones floating in a tank it's
been pretty clear that one of
lucasfilm's goals has been to dramatize
on screen the transitional period
between the original trilogy and the
sequel Trilogy which has already been
documented pretty well in books like
Chuck windig's aftermath series and
Claudia Gray's bloodline but by
exploring the spirit of history on
screen the goal seems to be to show less
literate Star Wars fans how exactly the
promising piece platform is secured by
Luke Skywalker Leia Organa Han Solo the
full Rebel Alliance led by brilliant
leaders like Mon mothma and Admiral
ekbar all of that fell apart so fast
within a single generation to justify
how and why the first order so
effectively caught everyone with their
pants down by turning the planet of ilum
where the Jedi would mine their crystals
for lightsabers into a planet-sized
death star that could destroy multiple
core worlds in a single blast the more
shows like Ahsoka and the Mandalorian
try to do this the more so far they have
been re-characterizing Heroes like Leia
Organa manmatma and Harrison Doula to be
at best naive and overwhelmed in their
attempts to maintain peace and deal with
the complexities of ruling a post-empire
Galaxy and at worst kinda dumb but
either way ineffective and incompetent
in ways that these characters should not
be and have never been before and also
in a way that's fully contradictory to
the nuanced takes of this political
transition by Chuck wendig an aftermath
and Claudia gray and bloodline is this
just something that we should entrust to
book writers and not screenwriters May B
especially when there are multiple
screenwriters who are writing for these
characters like think about it this is
tricky when we're facing the follow-up
season of Andor which needs us to see
mon mothma as a cautious strategist and
Savvy tactician and when we watch Andor
season 2 that is set in the same era as
Rebels leading up to the events of A New
Hope knowing all of mon matma's efforts
are just gonna lead to a New Republic
future 10 years from now where everyone
is this incompetent what's the point
like why even fight the Empire at that
point an Empire with one death star is
better than a first order with
Starkiller base I know it sounds like
I'm hating on Star Wars I I hate myself
right now but really my goal here is to
just point out how challenging it is to
try to fix eras of a non-sequentially
produced narrative timeline while still
furthering a compelling story with
characters we love and shows that are
titled about characters that should
really have nothing to do with the new
Republic anyway like overall I very much
enjoyed Dave filoni's work in Star Wars
I'm super grateful for what he's
bringing us I just think we need to talk
about whether trying to make what JJ
Abrams did in the force awakens make any
sense is really worth all this effort
for me it boy down to three issues one
the new Republic is just too forgiving
of ex-imperials two the new Republic is
too careless with Imperial hardware and
three lucasfilm is too focused on making
the new Republic look incompetent so I
just said two for giving too careless
and too focused but those are based not
on my standards but on the standards the
same creators already fought to make us
care about let's take these one by one
one the new Republic is too forgiving of
X Imperials so you may remember earlier
this year in season 3 episode 3 of the
Mandalorian we cut away from some
awesome aerial combat with Mando and
Boca time to Coruscant to catch up with
Dr Pershing a geneticist who formerly
served moff Gideon to see how he is
staring in the new Republic amnesty
program Persian gives a TED talk at the
Coruscant Opera House you remember that
it's the same one Anakin and Palpatine
convened with each other to chat about
Darth Plagueis the Wise and here
Pershing speaks about the merits of
cloning research the speech goes over so
well that afterwards he's fawned over by
New Republic High Society you know I was
almost drafted imagine me serving we're
darling that was the Empire my apologies
Empire rebels new Republic I can't keep
track my man it was 10 years ago yes
this episode seems to cast Pershing as a
kind of Warner Von Braun figure Warner
Von Braun being a German rocket engineer
who after World War II was recruited by
the United States under Operation
Paperclip and helped NASA build Rockets
an American story that had so glossed
over his Nazi roots and even made a Jake
Gyllenhaal 50s rocket movie about how
Werner Ron Braun was a hero whatever if
he inspired NASA to do cool things but
let's not forget he aimed rockets at
London but either way there is
historical precedent of The Winning Side
of History looking the other way to just
to score renowned scientists history is
complicated okay and I do kind of like
that Star Wars is drawing from that but
the difference between Pershing and
Warner Von Braun is pushing wasn't just
an ex-imperial from like 10 years prior
this guy continued serving Imperial
interests under moth Gideon 10 years
after the war is over so this would be
like if Warner Von Braun continued
building rockets for the Nazis in
Argentina in the 1950s and then went on
to Madison Square Garden and said he did
nothing wrong and NASA was like no
worries here's an apartment and a
clerical job for you like if lucasfilm
wants us to see the Empire as Space
Nazis cool they just really should read
up on what the Israeli Mossad did to
former Nazis in the 1960s those Nazis
who weasled out of Nuremberg were hunted
down and made to pay and then let's talk
about the character of Elia Kane Aaliyah
Kane is a fellow amnesty program recruit
who had served moff Gideon but in this
episode of the Mandalorian she's
revealed to be a kind of double agent
who catches Pershing in a new Republic's
sting operation and then we learned she
actually plans to steal his cloning
research and to fry his mind as she
still apparently serves Gideon in secret
a warlord who escaped New Republic trial
and was able to Rally an Army in a
shadow Council the new Republic sucks at
doing their jobs especially as we see
two episodes after this in the
Mandalorian where Tim Meadows shows up
as Colonel Tuttle and even defends the
former servant of the actively at large
warlord and war criminal after Carson
tiva begs him to just look into some
Rising instability on the Outer Rim I'm
requesting authorized Mission and backup
for dealing with pirates on Navarro sir
perhaps the leaders of Navarro need to
understand why becoming a republic
signatory is valuable by letting them
suffer sounds like a rather Imperial way
of thinking Captain you're out of line I
mean look we can point all kinds of
things to incompetence it's hard to do
your job and this ladies man here might
just be a bit over extended it's not
easy to govern a Galaxy this big but you
know what's less excusable is the
question of Imperial Hardware because
the second point the new Republic is too
careless with Imperial Hardware if
you've started planning your new
Halloween costume around your thinning
hair it might be time to try keeps keeps
is an online subscription service that
makes it easy and more affordable for
men to treat their male pattern baldness
right from home keeps offers both of the
FDA approved hair loss treatment options
as well as a two-in-one gel that
combines both treatments the treatments
offered by keeps are 90 effective at
treating hair loss and can increase hair
growth by up to 35 percent to get
started all you got to do is complete an
online consultation that'll get you
matched with the treatment plan tailored
to address your hair loss concerns once
you've done that choose the plan that
works for your schedule treatment plans
are affordable typically half the cost
of traditional Pharmacy prices with 3 6
and 12 month delivery options it's super
easy to adjust pause or cancel your plan
if you need to keeps has helped nearly 1
million men keep their hair which is
probably why it keeps us over 4 500 5
Star reviews hair loss stops with keeps
for a special offer to get started go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com new rockstars sure chapter
21 frames the Imperial Star Destroyers
being dismantled as a matter of the
transition just taking too long but in
Ahsoka it just gets real silly in
episode 2 Hera was shocked shocked to
learn that former Imperials were
overseeing the dismantling of Star
Destroyers on corellia something that's
both shocking and something she probably
should have known do the facilities
still employ any of her former staff he
will still find X Imperials at every
level of the new republic government
don't you worry about their loyalty not
at all yeah of course everyone who
worked here immediately reveals himself
to be former Space Nazis the moment hero
and Ahsoka start looking into it
committee about this Senator hamar
oziono rolls his eyes and Senator
Rodrigo has the gall to say we have
former Imperials working throughout
every level of the new republic
government and they've all taken an oath
of loyalty long live the Empire doesn't
sound like the kind of loyalty we're
looking for so the issue here is really
twofold a new republic government
overseen by badass political refugees
like mon mava would not accept loyalty
Oaths like they wouldn't put word of Von
Braun attractive dismantling actively
weaponizable B-52s without supervision
and Harrison Doula I love you but you're
a general in this government you
shouldn't be this out of the loop it's
just lucasfilm is pushing the
incompetence so hard and this is my
third point because weirdly lucasfilm is
just too focused on making the new
Republic incompetent and the biggest
problem there is that this incompetency
subplot is one of many subplots in these
shows that are just about too many
things for example notice that these
shows also cannot help but include
cameos and shout outs to every famous
Star Wars name that they can include in
episode 7 of Ahsoka Hera's tribunal is
overseen by Chancellor manmathma but
also on this panel of course is Admiral
Akbar and we learn Leia Organa is leader
of the defense Council until C-3PO
arrives Bon mappa looks resigned to
letting Senator ziono push through Hera
getting court-martialed Imperial
such a sensational term there is no
proof of any coordination between the
scattered and dwindling number of
Imperial forces I'll tell you what I see
I see a general who abuses her Authority
for personal gain I motion that General
sandula be court-martialed for
disobeying a direct order why does
mothman need Leia to bail her out now
sure Leia is a war hero everyone
respects her but everyone respects mon
mafa too she's a highly decorated hero
who put everything on the line by
fleeing the Senate and speaking out
against the Gorman Massacre polony knows
about that Gorman history he wrote that
storyline in Rebels de Palani wrote Bon
moth by shouting down a much larger
Hollow projection of Saw Guerrera so why
now when Mothman has much less to lose
is she letting ziono walk all over her I
mean hey maybe there's a good reason we
don't know about but there's no time to
explore it because this is not a new
Republic show it's Ahsoka it's a show
about Ahsoka it's a bead and like a half
a dozen other things so why are we also
spending so much time on this new
Republic look I'll say bringing
ziono in was a smart move because he was
a prick in resistance he fits the bill
perfectly but just imagine if he was the
only representative of the new republic
government on the series an argument
could be made that hey maybe the reason
the new Republic fails is it just
because mama have to rely too much on
corrupt arrogant politicians and they're
just not able to oversee this many parts
of their government that's essentially
Claudia Gray's assessment bloodline
makes sense really the move here is to
just bring in a new character we are
okay hating and blame them for the new
Republic collapsing like Andor has done
a really good job of this by bringing in
new faces like Lutheran Cyril car and
dejramiro major partagas as complex
humans whose quirks and strengths can be
used to justify these Rebel wins and
losses without changing the way we judge
any classic Star Wars figures mon mothma
Leia Organa and Harrison Doula are smart
they are good leaders they deserve to be
written that way every time they show up
in Star Wars but right now they're being
written in this weird way just so that
the force awakens better fits in with
Return of the Jedi can we all just
accept that with the force awakens JJ
Abrams and lucasfilm and Disney learn
the wrong lessons from the prequel era
and forced episode 7 to be too much of a
Redux of A New Hope and Starkiller base
is kind of nuts but that's okay and it
doesn't have to make sense and it's
still a really fun movie anyway can we
just make the Mandalorian show about a
cuckoo had armored stunt actors kicking
each other's asses and helmet culture
can Ahsoka just be a show about Star
maps and Witchcraft and the scars of Bad
Teachers okay rant over I'm back to just
appreciating craft I know that's what
you guys subscribe for him sorry about
this I still think there's so much to
love about the show and I swear I'm not
going down the path of the Star Wars
YouTube dark side but comment down below
I want to hear from you am I missing
something about these new Republic
scenes on the Mandalorian and Ahsoka hit
me up in the comments and please
subscribe to all three of our channels
in the new rockstars Network and I'll
see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you